Welcome back to another episode of
What's Up Prof?
Welcome Walter.
Welcome Martin.
Where we're privileged to have a sponsor
specifying that we
have to get new chairs and supplying us
Which is not an easy task in in the
areas where we live, right? No.
So, just for information, it took us
1,200
and something kilometers
to finally get two chairs that are
alike.
Not too easy. It wasn't too easy and
just for everybody's information, these
chairs are really comfortable.
That's a problem because what if we fall
asleep?
Well, it's amazing your feet actually
touch the ground.
ground, yeah. I know.
And uh your arms are not around your
ears. I don't know what we're going to
do now.
No, so thank you and I hope everybody
will enjoy this just as much as we do.
Yes, thank you very much. It's very
kind.
So, we've got some important things to
start off with.
Let's open with a word of prayer.
Our heavenly Father, thank you very much
for everything you do for us.
Lord, we need you in these discussions
and we ask that you bless us. We ask for
the Holy Spirit's enlightenment
and discernment
that we can know
what is right and what is not. We ask
this in Jesus' name. Amen. Amen.
Martin, deception is the name of the
game, isn't it? Definitely. Now,
deception can look like the real thing.
And uh
we are seeing so many things happening
in the world and the arguments
that are always presented in favor of
the events as they are taking place or
at least the moral issues
seem very convincing to some.
But they are based on criteria which are
not biblical. Mhm.
So,
there's a serious choice to be made.
And the problem is
that the media keeps bombarding you with
this unidirectional
mindset. No wonder the Bible says the
whole world wondered after the beast
received the same mindset. Yes. If you
keep pushing that agenda
and you say something long enough,
eventually people think, "Well, that's
the right thing to do, right?" Correct.
And it's important it's to wonder with a
O.
So, it's in awe of. It's Yes. gra-
taking up everything that the beast is
telling them. Absolutely.
So,
understanding Pope Francis is what we
are calling deception. Mhm.
And there'll be more than one
Definitely.
of these discussions because you cannot
unravel it in one. It's impossible.
But we've done the best we can under the
circumstances.
Understanding Pope Francis, the Jesuit
agenda. Why is it important to
understand Pope Francis?
Because, Martin,
within the Roman Catholic circles, there
are many that don't understand him.
Correct. They think he's a complete
liberal.
He's bringing in a liberal agenda. He's
changing the face of the Roman Catholic
Church.
And they are complaining bitterly.
And you know what's interesting? Mhm.
That the Protestant world
Yes. looks at these conservative
Catholics and says, "See, the papacy has
changed."
Correct.
Even they are complaining.
Yes.
So,
all right, maybe he's going so liberal
that even Protestants get a little bit
shaky here and there and wonder what is
going on. But the fact of the matter is
they are changing and the general
direction
seems the one that everybody should go.
Yes, and then you've also got the
Protestant world
that sees this
change
and now they can go into ecumenical
council with us.
Absolutely because, you know, the papacy
of the Middle Ages is gone.
Mhm.
That Council of Trent papacy is gone. It
doesn't exist.
Well, that's what they That's what they
believe.
Mhm.
But that's where the deception comes in.
Correct.
So, in order to make it absolutely
clear, we are going to talk about this
issue.
If you understand the issues behind the
scenes
Mhm.
and you start understanding where this
Pope comes from,
then you will see that nothing has
changed.
Correct.
And it's
falling into place.
Yes, it is the chameleon at its best.
Yeah, definitely. Hiding itself in the
foliage and
taking up the background so that you
don't see it for what it is.
So, let's look at this issue of
understanding Pope Francis.
Here's an article from Reuters, May 25,
2021.
Pope launches green initiative decrying
predatory attitude towards the planet.
Now, this is a a relatively modern
issue, so people would think. But it's
not.
It's an issue that has been coming for a
long time and we need to go to the root
in order to see
that we are now at the tip of the
iceberg. Yes.
Pope Francis launched an initiative on
Tuesday to make Catholic institutions
ranging from families to universities to
business
is environmentally sustainable in 7
years
saying a predatory attitude towards the
planet must end.
So, he's given a 7-year period. Mhm.
Maybe he knows something. Okay.
At a news conference announcing the
initiative, Cardinal Peter Turkson, head
of the Vatican development office, said
the Pope has been
invited to attend the United Nations
Climate Change Conference COP26
in November in Glasgow, Scotland.
So, there is a a drive towards this
COP26
conference.
And we've spoken about that before, so
we're we're not looking at that. We're
looking at the history and where this
all comes from.
So, Turkson indicated that the Pope
likely will attend. In a video message
for the launch, the Pope said the
initiative would be a 7-year journey
that will see our communities committed
in different ways to becoming totally
sustainable
in the spirit of
integral
ecology.
That means you must be slotted in.
Mhm.
There's no way that you can escape this,
right? Correct.
Now, he's setting the tune, isn't he?
Yes. Okay.
Taking the lead.
The initiative will have focus groups
including families, parishes,
dioceses, schools, universities,
hospitals, and other health care
facilities, businesses, lay Catholic
organizations, and orders of priests and
nuns.
That's the whole spectrum. Mhm. There's
nothing excluded, right?
No. That's talking about the Catholics,
but it will definitely incorporate the
whole world.
The whole world.
And it's always interesting how you
start with the family unit
Mhm. because the papacy uses the family
unit
in order to push its Sunday agenda.
Yes. Correct. And then it has the health
message in there as well.
So, healing is a right arm to its
message. We've said that before.
So, since Laudato Si, praised be, was
published in 2015, the Vatican and
Catholic groups in the 1.3 billion
member church around the world have
taken many initiatives to reduce their
carbon footprint.
So, this is the 7-year plan. Yes. Now,
it's really kicking in now because just
the Laudato Si year just expired now and
then Pope Francis came in there was the
7-year plan now.
Martin, is he date setting?
This is a very dangerous trend.
Uh the theologians must take note and
say that date setting is not
permissible.
And what's also necessary to take note
of
it was like we were saying
he's speaking of the of the Catholic
Church today.
But is Pope Francis really
uh just a Catholic Church man?
Or is he a leader in the world? You see
some people say
what does it matter what he says? He's
just a church leader, right? But it's
not the case. We need to understand
this.
So, we're now going to look at an
interview with John Kerry.
Now, as you know, he's a Skull and Bones
member.
So, he belongs to the secret societies.
Uh chapter 322 and all of these
wonderful things that we've discussed in
many previous lectures.
And what is his opinion of the position
of the Pope in all of this? It's
important that we get it from the most
powerful nation in the world.
Yes, like you said.
An important leader
in the most powerful country in the
world.
Correct. With a very powerful position.
You're on a a very important
mission here to Europe. Can you tell us
why is it important to include a visit
with the Pope during your visit to to
Europe to talk about climate change?
Well, the Pope is one of the great
voices
of reason and compelling moral authority
on the subject of the climate crisis.
He's been ahead of the curve. He's been
a leader.
His encyclical Laudato Si is really a
very very powerful document.
Uh eloquent and morally very persuasive.
And I think that
his voice will be a very important voice
leading up to and through the Glasgow
conference.
How can the United States as a
superpower
and the Holy See as a much smaller
country but nonetheless as a moral and
spiritual authority
uh collaborate in the fight against
climate change?
Well, the Holy Father is one of if not
the one of the most powerful voices on
the planet and he's been
uh extraordinary in the eloquence of his
uh
call on people to to to step up and be
reasonable and to live out our
responsibility as human beings in caring
for God's creation.
Um and and we all have to be stewards of
that creation. That's his message.
Uh but because he is above politics and
outside of the hurly-burly of day-to-day
um
uh national
uh
conflict etc.
I think he can sort of
you know, shake people a little bit and
bring them to the table with a better
sense of our common obligation.
And I think the Holy Father speaks with
special authority to our sense of
obligation to each other uh and the ways
in which we need to all step up now
together
uh given the divisions of the world and
some of the polarization and the
ideology and conflict
um that voice is more important than
ever.
Now Martin, that is a very astounding
interview, isn't it?
Definitely. The setting under that
picture
Yes.
showing all those Popes Mhm. and the
interesting thing about those Popes
uh they are the Popes of Vatican II
mainly.
Yes. Right?
Mhm. And he's
he's towering above them.
Yep.
And the other thing is the most
power one of the most prominent if not
the most prominent voices in the world.
And he is going to be the moral voice of
reason.
It's interesting that the Georgia
Guidestones talk about this age of
reason, right? Yep. And we must stop
being parasites on the planet.
So, all of this is very very important
and leading up to this COP26
meeting in Glasgow.
So, interesting things are lying ahead
and therefore it is essential
that we understand where this is coming
from and what the mindset behind it is.
Definitely.
So Martin, it is
essential that we also understand
where the moral compass Mhm.
of Pope Francis comes from.
Yes, because like Kerry said, he's the
moral leader. Yes. So, you have to know
what type of morality are we talking?
Exactly. Now
they class themselves as a Christian
institution
and we've had some WhatsApp profs about
the doctrine of the serpent.
Mhm.
In the past, people might want to
take cognizance of those again.
Mhm.
But
the morality
is not based upon
the word of God. No. The morality is
based on something entirely different.
Correct. It's a spirituality
that has no connection
to the Bible whatsoever.
Mhm. And we need to make this quite
clear.
So, we need to go into the Jesuit roots
and see where the morality comes from.
Yes.
And why it is such a dangerous morality.
Yeah, it's important to understand where
Pope Francis comes from. Yes.
Now, this comes from America, the Jesuit
Review YouTube channel.
And the picture on the front is about
Father Sosa's new book. He's of course
the head of the Jesuit order.
And he's saying walking with Ignatius.
In other words, this whole issue is
Ignatius spirituality. Ignatius, the
founder of the Jesuit order.
And of course
all Jesuits have to be steeped in
Ignatian spirituality.
Yes. So, we need to know where that
comes from.
And Pope Francis being a Jesuit is also
steeped in Ignatian spirituality.
spirituality.
All right, let's have a look at this.
So, we we do have to ask um since you
are the Superior General of the of the
Jesuits and Pope Francis is our first
Jesuit Pope, who's who's in charge
between the two of you? Do you do you
report to him or does he report to you?
He is the Pope.
Pope.
So, it's very clear.
But he's still a Jesuit.
Every Jesuit
reports to the Pope to the Pope. Mhm. I
is
maybe to to to explain
that when a Jesuit
becomes a bishop
he the obedience is not more is not any
more for the superiors of the society.
No, the bishop depends on the Pope and
the Pope depends
on himself.
On the spirit.
So, because as you maybe remember
Ignatius de Loyola used to
call the Pope the vicar of Christ in
earth.
So, he's the Pope.
So, I'm accountable to him.
So, what is interesting
uh in this discussion, we will look at
more of this discussion because there
are very very pertinent statements that
are being made.
So, number one that is important in this
section is that the Pope is dependent
upon himself. Yes.
He is the ultimate voice, the one who
decides.
Later on in the interview, he he claims
that he as the Jesuit order's head is
the neck.
Which is a good analogy because uh it'll
say where it has to go and sometimes a
general
as we saw in Creto Malta have has to
make his own decisions.
And they all walk according to the
drumbeat, right?
Correct. Correct. And that's how they
organize the world. Maybe maybe I can
just add here. It's important if
somebody doesn't know what you're
talking about now, I'll put the link in
to Creto Malta where they can go and
watch
um where we're talking about the art of
war. That's it. Correct. So, perhaps
that would be interesting to put that
link in.
So, basically we're looking at the
structure generally, but we will
continue.
How being a Jesuit has shaped him as
Pope. Uh you know, he's somebody who
talks a lot about discernment which is a
really important part of Jesuit
spirituality and I'm wondering if you
could talk a little bit about um you
know, what what we can all learn from
Pope Francis about discernment.
Pope Francis
uh is not only a Jesuit, he's a
Christian.
And discernment is is part of
Christianity. We are about to celebrate
Pentecost in a few days, so we can renew
our idea of a being guided by the
spirit. Discernment is the skill every
Christian needs to be guided by the Holy
Spirit.
And that's why Ignatian spirituality
is so pointed on that, and Ignatian
spiritual exercises
are a kind of discernment school.
Mhm. That he he uh
learning himself. So, following the
spiritual exercises, every person
can be helped to hear the voice of God
calling him to a fully human life and to
decide to follow that voice, not to take
a to make an election.
And then
uh and you can also maybe remember that
the the success of Ignatius with the
spiritual exercises were among
university students. He was Mhm.
university, and all university student,
and he
get together
with some young university students. All
the first companions of Ignatius
were university students gathered by the
experience of the spiritual exercises.
That's right.
Uh the this is school of discernment
has been a very very fruitful for for us
in all the stage of our life and
apostolate. Yeah. So, so all Jesuits do
the spiritual exercises, but one thing
that's always struck me struck me about
the society is the the diverse
directions that Jesuits go on from
there. So, you have Jesuits who are
teachers, doctors, actors, podcasters,
uh everything you can think of. Um and
you know, that's clearly part of the
Jesuit charism and a strength of the
order.
Um but as the person who's on top of
that at the neck, how do you how do you
manage such a diverse workforce?
Well, that's beautiful. I
every day I discover something new that
Jesuits are doing.
All right.
Very very important.
The discernment comes through the
spiritual exercises. Yes.
Correct? Mhm.
And the spiritual exercises of Loyola
are the means whereby you connect to the
Holy Spirit to be informed and to
receive discernment.
Not the word of God. No.
Spiritual exercises.
So, that is very important. And then the
other issue that he mentioned was to
live a truly human life.
Now, in Jesuit thinking and Jesuit
theology,
there is a book written by another
Jesuit which is called
No Other Name.
Mhm. Question mark. Yes.
So, can you be saved by any other name
than Jesus Christ? And then the answer,
of course, in that book is of course,
you can be saved in any religious
system. Jesus Christ is not the only
way.
Sure.
So,
We cannot
that is very important.
And he defines to be saved
as living a truly human life.
Yeah.
That's very very interesting.
So, to be saved to a Bible-believing
person
is to have this knowledge that Jesus
Christ has paid the price for you,
that through his atonement, through his
blood, you by faith
can be part of the kingdom of God.
Not within.
No. Not according to them. It's a living
a truly human life. In other words,
everybody has to come on to a level
where everybody lives happily on Earth.
That's the kingdom on Earth. Yes. I'm
not looking for a kingdom on Earth. I
can keep it.
And this is linking in with this whole
world economic forum
plan of everybody
owning nothing and being happy. Yes, and
having the same basic income.
Correct.
Uh so, very interesting. So, the
spirituality, we need to understand
where it comes from.
Because people think that this
spirituality, this discernment, being a
Christian so-called institution, comes
from the word of God. It doesn't. Yes.
That's important.
It's very important because a lot of
this sounds great.
All right. So, now let's just go back in
history and have a look at this from all
of these perspectives. The reasons why
the Jesuits are even there are very
important, and I know we pushed this
agenda, but people forget.
And the worst thing you can do is to
have to repeat history because you
forgot the history of the past. Yes. And
it won't be necessary to repeat it if we
could see that some people did not
forget this. But what we see is that
people did forget this.
And then they join in ecumenical
councils with Correct. Absolutely
correct.
So, here is an a quote which is very
relevant. I cannot too much impress upon
the minds of my readers that the Jesuits
by their very calling,
by the very essence of their
institution, are bound to seek by every
means, right or wrong, the destruction
of Protestantism.
This is the condition of their
existence, the duty they must fulfill,
or cease to be Jesuits.
Accordingly, we find them in this evil
dilemma. Either the Jesuits fulfill the
duties of their calling or not.
In the first instance, they must be
considered as the biggest enemies of the
Protestant faith.
In the second, as bad and unworthy
priests. And in both cases,
to therefore to be equally regarded with
aversion and distrust.
That's history.
Comes from the history of the Jesuits.
Mhm. Their origin, progress, doctrine,
and design.
Let's go
to the great battle between the Catholic
system, where the Jesuits created to
spearhead that battle
for the Catholics, and Martin Luther.
Martin Luther's appeal was to submit the
conscience directly to God through the
word.
And Loyola's drive was to submit the
conscience to the papacy.
Ignatian spirituality was to be achieved
through spiritual exercises by
substituting imagination
and encounter theology for the reality
of faith.
So, the discernment
that the Jesuits seeks comes through
imagination
and spiritual exercises. So, we need to
understand how it works. It's not
word-based. No.
And it's also necessary to understand
this because they've Christianized
this whole
um imagination and encounter theology of
them. Yes. So, there's a lot
it's also infiltrated Protestant
churches. Oh, Protestant churches run on
spiritual exercises without knowing it.
Yes.
So, uh Ignatius Loyola and Martin Luther
were of course contemporaries.
Let's see what Martin Luther wrote.
He wrote, "The Holy Scriptures are full
of divine gifts and virtues. The books
of the heathen taught nothing of faith,
hope, or charity.
They present no idea of these things.
They contemplate only the present and
that which man, with the use of his
material reason,
can grasp and comprehend.
Look not therein for aught of hope or
trust in God.
But see how the Psalms and the Book of
Job treat of faith, hope, resignation,
and prayer.
In a word, the Holy Scripture is the
highest and best of books,
abounding in comfort under all
afflictions and trials.
It teaches us to see, to feel, to grasp,
and to comprehend faith, hope, and
charity far otherwise than mere human
reason can.
And when evil oppresses us, it teaches
us how these virtues throw light upon
the darkness, and how after this poor,
miserable existence of ours on Earth,
there is another and eternal life.
You see, Martin, how word-based Martin
Luther's thinking was.
And he said that this human reason
cannot even grasp the depth of divine
reason.
The Holy Scriptures surpass in
efficaciousness all the arts and all the
sciences of the philosophers and
jurists.
These, though good and necessary to life
here below, are vain and of no effect
as to what concerns the eternal life.
The Bible should be regarded with holy
different eyes from those with which we
view other productions. He who wholly
renounces himself and relies not on mere
human reason
will make good progress in the
scriptures.
But the world comprehends them not
from ignorance of the most mortification
which is the gift of God's word.
Can he who understands not God's word
understand God's works?
This is manifest
Cain, that is possessor, householder.
This son Adam and Eve thought would be
the man of God, the blessed seed that
would crush the serpent's head.
Afterwards when Eve was with child
again, they hoped to have a daughter
that their beloved son Cain might have a
wife.
But Eve bearing again a son called him
Abel,
that is vanity and nothingness, as much
as to say, "My hope is gone and I am
deceived."
This was an image of the world and of
God's church, showing how things have
ever gone. The ungodly Cain
was a great lord in the world, while
Abel, that upright and pious man, was an
outcast, subject and oppressed.
But before God, the case was quite
contrary.
Cain was rejected of God, Abel accepted
and received as God's beloved child.
The like is daily seen here on earth.
Therefore, let us not heed its doings.
Ishmael's was also a fair name, hero of
God,
while Isaac's was not.
Esau's name means actor,
the man that shall do the work. Jacob's
was not.
The name Absalom signifies father of
peace.
Such fair and glorious colors do the
ungodly ever bear in this world,
while in truth and deed they are
condemners,
scoffers, and rebels to the word of God.
Martin, this man had Wow. insight,
right?
That's amazing how he put it. It's
amazing how he writes.
But by that word, we, God be praised,
are able to discern and know all such.
For Martin Luther, discernment was
learned in the school of the word. Mhm.
Therefore, let us hold the Bible in
precious esteem and diligently read it.
To world wisdom,
there seems no lighter or more easy art
than divinity.
And the understanding of God's word, so
that the children of the world will be
reputed fully versed in scripture and
catechism, but they shoot far from the
mark.
I would give all my fingers, save three
to write with, could I find divinity so
easily and light as they take it to be.
The reason why men deem it so
is that they become soon wearied and
think they know enough of it. So we
found it in the world, and so we must
leave it.
But in fine, videbatur curios toni,
I have many times
essayed thoroughly to investigate the
Ten Commandments, but at the very
outside,
"I am the Lord thy God," I stuck fast.
That very one word, "I,"
put me to the nonplus.
He that has but one word of God before
him, and out of that word cannot make a
sermon,
can never be a preacher.
I am well content that I know however
little of what God's word is and take
good heed not to murmur at my small
knowledge.
Now, that was a long quote. Yeah, but
it's beautiful. It has so much depth to
it. And it tells you that your reason
cannot fathom God. Yes, the way he said
that the names, the biblical names that
were
uh
earth earthly were the great ones.
And it is like that to this day.
Yes. So be careful of that great name,
huh?
But this has to do with discernment Mhm.
and spirituality. Where does it come
from? What is the source? What is the
root?
Let's go to the other side
and see where Ignatius Loyola's
spirituality came from.
Now, this is an excellent source that is
Aubigné's History of the Reformation of
the 16th century.
And it is written in that, "Inigo, which
was a nickname for Ignatius,
instead of feeling that his remorse was
sent to drive him to the foot of the
cross,
persuaded himself that these inward
reproaches proceeded not from God, but
from the devil.
And he resolved never more to think of
his sins, to erase them from his memory,
and bury them in eternal oblivion.
Luther turned towards Christ, Loyola
only fell upon himself.
Visions came ere long to confirm Inigo
in the convictions
at which he had arrived.
Inigo did not seek truth in the Holy
Scriptures,
but imagined in their place immediate
communication with the world of spirits.
Luther on taking his doctor's degree had
pledged his oath to the Holy Scripture.
Loyola at his time bound himself to
dreams and visions, and to miracle
apparitions became the principle of his
life and his faith.
In other words, Martin Luther also
experienced remorse for his sins.
And like Loyola and the Jesuit order,
and like is customary in Catholic
thinking, chastised himself. He beat
himself. He fasted to the point of
starvation. He slept on the hard ground
without a blanket. He punished himself.
And he found no relief.
And so
eventually
he discovered that relief in the
scriptures.
Inigo had the same experience.
But he chose the path of
imagined spirituality,
having immediate contact with the other
world.
And it became a reality.
The spirits actually spoke to him.
Correct. And through the imagination,
which is actually a form of
self-hypnosis,
he entered into that other realm. And
once you are in that realm, you are open
to the spirit.
But Martin, shouldn't you test the
spirit? Correct. Against what? Against
what? That is the question.
Don't you have to have a standard and a
norm whereby to test the spirit?
Definitely. Now, if you cut out the
scripture,
then what do you test the spirit by? By
the next spirit? Correct. So if somebody
has a spirit, and that spirit coincides
with a spirit that I have, is that a
confirmation? For for that person, yes.
For that person, yes. Very dangerous.
Yes, no, definitely. And also,
it says there, "Loyola only fell upon
himself."
That sounds similar to what the Jesuit
general said. Exactly. Pope Francis has
to fall back on himself.
himself and upon his spirituality. And
that's where he gets the connection.
So Martin, in order to understand Pope
Francis a little bit better,
we need to look at his history
and see how he developed within the
Jesuit order and how his spirituality
developed.
So CNN
actually did a little series on Pope
Francis.
And there's an article, Dark Night of
the Soul,
where they discuss his growth with
within the system.
So let's have a look at some of those
issues so that we can understand what we
are dealing with.
This is Cordoba, a city in the heart of
Argentina.
More than a million people live here,
but in the 1990s, this was a lonely
place for the man who would become Pope
Francis.
Jorge Bergoglio, that's the Pope's name
before he was Francis, used to live in
Buenos Aires,
where he had a reputation for being more
drill sergeant than a man of mercy.
He would tell priests what to read, how
to dress, even how to pray.
Finally, the Jesuits decided they'd had
enough.
They sent him 500 miles away to Cordoba,
basically hoping to get rid of him.
So how did this man who was exiled not
only become Pope,
but become a rock star Pope? As His
Holiness Pope Francis has said,
"Diplomacy is the work of small steps."
I want to thank and recognize the
support of the Vatican and especially
Pope Francis for the improvement of
relationships between Cuba and the
United States. I love this guy.
Nice to meet you.
Javier Sebastian, a local journalist in
Cordoba.
Smelled good.
Who fed me well
and gave me their perspective on how the
city changed the man.
You can hear the sadness in the Pope's
own words.
Ricardo Spinassi was one of the Pope's
closest friends.
He read me a poem that Francis wrote
about being lost on a dark night with
only the stars to keep him company.
Ricardo told me that if I really wanted
to know what happened during the Pope's
dark nights, I should talk to his
spiritual son, Father Angel Rossi.
How long have you been here? 18 year
here.
The Pope drinking a mate? That's a big
mate. He looks happy.
It's beautiful. How long was this? Yes.
He took me to the chapel where the Pope
prayed alone every morning.
Rossi said that the Pope suffered
terribly during his exile and friends
were actually worried about his mental
health.
Wow.
Father Rossi showed me the actual room
where Francis lived.
He would pray and write and read in
here? Yes.
Very simple, very humble.
In the end, it's not exactly clear what
happened to Pope Francis during his
exile in Cordoba.
But he says that he came back more
merciful and kinder.
So it seems like whatever happened here
clearly had a lasting impact on Pope
Francis.
So Martin,
there are some that claim that in that
dark night
he actually had similar experiences to
those of Ignatius Loyola.
Because he practiced those spiritual
exercises. It is part of the program.
Every Jesuit has to go through the
spiritual exercises.
And there he had this encounter
theology. The inner inner spirituality
as it was mentioned in the video that he
had to discover. Yes. And as the Jesuit
General said, he was formed by the
spiritual exercises.
So this is where this contemplative
religion
formed him.
Not the word of God.
Let's just look at some of the quotes
regarding the spirituality
and the Pope's dark night of the soul.
It takes more than a decade for Jesuits
to complete their training, which
includes theological and philosophical
studies, hands-on ministry, and intense
spiritual retreats.
The idea is to train a company of men
able to go anywhere and fulfill any
mission, all for the greater glory of
God.
In actual fact, that greater glory is
the greater glory of the Pope.
Bergoglio, Pope Francis, was appointed
provincial of the Argentine Jesuits when
he was just 36. The Society of Jesus
divides itself into geographical regions
called provinces, which are led by
provincials who serve 6-year terms.
After serving in high-powered posts like
provincials, many Jesuits are demoted to
discourage careerism and ambition,
a sin that Ignatius called the mother of
evils.
But Sweenen succeeded Bergoglio as
provincial and made his friend rector of
the Collegio Maximo, a decision that
would divide the province for decades.
Even more troublesome for the province,
his devotees honored Bergoglio's every
word as holy writ.
And after holding high Jesuit office for
15 years, he had attracted a sizable
entourage, perhaps 40% of the province.
Finally, Bergoglio's bosses decided
they'd had enough. They shipped him off
to Cordoba, 500 miles away.
And now comes
the essence. What happened to him there?
Yes. So let's just make it quite plain
again.
He was basically exiled and demoted,
right?
Correct. But that's part of their
training. Yes. So we shouldn't
misunderstand that. It's part of the
plan. It happens to all of them.
And also just for interest's sake, this
dark night of the soul
was actually a poem that was written by
St. John of the Cross, also Catholic but
a mystic. Absolutely. So you get all
sorts of
intertwining
nuances, interesting nuances.
Yes.
All right. So
what did he do in those time periods
when he was away? Drawing on the
spiritual exercises,
the set of prayers and contemplations he
learned decades before as a Jesuit
novice,
he explores the difference between
self-pity and self-sacrifice.
The Reverend Angel Rossi, a man Pope
Francis refers to as his spiritual son,
describes Pope Francis as follows.
He's humble but confident, a disciplined
rule-breaker. He's deeply spiritual but
crafty,
a cross between a desert saint and a
shrewd politician. He's a man of power
and action who spends a great deal of
time in prayer and contemplation.
It is a description many Jesuits might
recognize in themselves. Contradiction
is part of who we are, Rossi said.
This is part of the training.
So in this contemplation, which is what
Ignatius taught them and which he
experienced, they find their
spirituality and their reason and their
discernment.
All right. Here is another Jesuit
uh who will explain this issue. The
Jesuit spirituality of Pope Francis.
As Jesuits, Pope Francis and I have much
in common. We have been formed, so to
speak, by the same spirituality
during long years of Jesuit training as
well as in the years since then.
In what follows, I reflect from the
inside on some of the key
characteristics of Jesuit spirituality
in terms of the insight they can provide
into the world's first Jesuit Pope.
A sinner called to be a companion in
Christ's mission. Central to every
Jesuit
is the experience of the spiritual
exercises of St. Ignatius of Loyola, who
founded the Society of Jesus,
alternatively known as the Jesuits.
Every Jesuit
does the full 30-day exercises at the
start and at the end of his training and
also usually a shorter version of these
exercises annually.
Finding God in everyone and everywhere.
That's interesting, right?
That's really interesting. Yes. Finding
him everywhere. That is pantheism.
Yes. In many ways,
it is almost like certain forms of
Buddhism. Yes.
Where you eventually fuse
and become part of the divine.
So this is a very occult experience.
A second characteristic of Jesuit
spirituality
is its emphasis on being able to find
God in all people,
in all places, and in all things. That's
pantheism.
And in a higher sense, panentheism,
which allows for a personal side of God.
Yes. Francis was the master of Jesuit
novices, to use the traditional title in
Argentina, when he was a young man.
So he trained them. Yes. That's what he
did. He led out
retreats and all of it.
In this role, he had to be able to give
the spiritual exercises to those
considering becoming Jesuits, which
meant that he had to know the exercises
very well.
The characteristic of finding God
present in everyone and everywhere also
makes Jesuit spirituality
world-embracing,
Open to people of other religious
traditions
and none.
So, that's why they can incorporate
atheists or
pantheists or any system, shamans,
anything. Arms are wide open to receive
all of these.
And open to seeing goodwill in everyone.
Francis is well known for this openness.
And then the discernment.
My emphasis on how Jesuit spirituality
is at work in Francis makes us aware
that while he is clearly an admirer of
Francis of Assisi and inspired by him,
he is nevertheless, I would say, first
and foremost a follower of St. Ignatius.
And he is in no doubt about that
himself.
Returning from Brazil, he said the
following in his unscripted interview
with the journalists on the plane
traveling with him.
So, now let's look at his own words.
I feel myself a Jesuit in my
spirituality.
In the spirituality of the exercises,
the spirituality I have in my heart, I
feel so much like this that in 3 days
I'll go to celebrate with Jesuits the
feast of St. Ignatius.
I will say the morning mass. I haven't
changed my spirituality. No, Francis
Franciscan. No, I feel myself a Jesuit
and I think like a Jesuit.
I think Martin, that should make it
pretty clear to the listeners that
Francis is steeped
in the spiritual exercises of Loyola.
Correct. They are his norm. They are his
standard. They are his guide. They are
his source of discernment.
I think it's important that we just
briefly go back in history and just look
at what the spiritual exercises actually
entail.
Definitely. That's most important
because now we've said
he is steeped in those spirituality and
those exercises. Uh But Yes.
people might not know what it entails.
Exactly. And it's very important that we
know why.
Because this is not only going to
concern Pope Francis.
Mhm. It's going to concern the whole
world.
The whole world, yes. Because this
discernment,
this
spirituality
is what has to be superimposed
upon the whole of humanity, including
you and me.
Mhm.
I refuse to be part of it.
Because like Martin Luther, I will take
my stand on the word and that's where my
discernment and my spirituality must
come from. Correct.
So, this here is uh
information from the spiritual exercises
of St. Ignatius Loyola, translated from
the autograph by Father Elder Mullan,
Society of Jesus, New York. So, this is
how it worked. Let's go back and see
what he did.
The call of the temporal king.
It helps to contemplate the life of the
king eternal. And here you have the
first basic premise.
You don't go directly to that eternal
king. You go to the temporal king. In
other words, you make a human being your
example.
And this is where the Pope comes in.
He takes the place.
Mhm.
He is the vicar of Christ on earth. He
takes the place of Jesus Christ. And if
that spirituality that comes from there
is contemplative,
then that is what you receive.
Then you have bypassed Jesus Christ.
So, it starts with a prayer. Let the
preparatory prayer be the usual one.
First prelude.
The first prelude is a composition,
seeing the place.
It will be here to see with the sight of
the imagination, the synagogue, the
villages, the towns through which Christ
our Lord preached.
So, you're now in your imagination or
going into the scene. Visualization.
Visualization.
Then the second prelude. The second to
ask for the grace which I want. First
point.
The first point is to put before me a
human king
chosen by God our Lord, whom all
Christian princes and men revere and
obey.
Immediately Christ is sidelined. He's
substituted.
Second point.
The second to look how this king speaks
to all his people, saying,
"It is my will to conquer all the land
of unbelievers. Therefore, whoever would
like to come with me to be content to
eat as I and also to drink and dress,
etc. as I. Likewise, he is to labor like
me in the day and watch in the night,
etc. So that afterwards he may have part
with me in the victory as he has had it
in the labors."
There goes your individuality. You've
just sacrificed it. Correct.
Third point.
The third to consider what the good
subjects are ought to answer.
Fourth rule.
To praise much religious orders,
virginity, continents, and not so much
marriage as any of these.
So, if you want to be a Jesuit,
you have to get rid of everything that
is normal and natural for humanity that
God has placed within humanity.
You have to cut off your natural
feelings. You have to cut off your
natural emotions. You have to cut off
your natural attractions.
And you have to separate them
from your life. Because they get in the
way, Martin.
Mhm.
Of your one goal.
The fifth rule. To praise vows of
religion, of obedience, of poverty, of
chastity, and of other perfections of
supererogation.
In other words, you have to go through
all of these motions and all of these
fasts and all of these things and all of
these vows.
And not the word of God. You don't
contemplate God. You contemplate the
system.
Sixth rule.
To praise the relics of the saints.
Mhm.
Now, excuse me, Martin. Isn't that
against the second commandment? Yes,
that's
idolization.
Isn't that one of the reasons why Rome
had to remove that commandment? Mhm.
Yes. So, to praise the relics of the
saints, you're not allowed to worship
anything. Not above the earth, not under
the earth, nothing that is dead.
Yeah. Do not be defiled by the dead,
says the Bible. They do exactly the
opposite. In that
in that um article, Dark Night of the
Soul, it also mentions there that in
that chapel where Pope Francis used to
pray, he was praying there
and there was a lot of
Jesuit relics
in the chapel.
So, to praise the relics of the saints,
giving veneration to them,
that's contrary to the word of God. And
praying to the saints, you were not
allowed to consult the dead.
And to praise stations, pilgrimages,
indulgences, pardons, crusades, candles
lighted in the churches.
Martin,
do you find that anywhere in the
scriptures? No.
Seventh rule. To praise constitutions
about fasts and abstinence as of Lent,
Ember days, vigils, Friday and Saturday
like why penances, not only interior but
also exterior.
That means you had to chastise yourself
physically. Beat yourself.
Is that biblical? No.
Wasn't Christ treated as we deserve so
that we might be treated as he deserves?
Yes.
The eighth rule
is to praise the ornaments and the
buildings of the churches. What is that,
Martin? Idolatry. Correct. Likewise,
images and to venerate them according to
what they represent.
To have the true sentiment which we
ought to have in the church militant,
let the following rules be observed.
First rule. The first.
All judgment laid aside, we ought to
have our mind ready and prompt to obey
in all the true spouse of Christ our
Lord, which is our holy mother the
church hierarchical.
So, that's the first rule. You may have
no judgment of yourself.
What about choose thee this day whom you
will serve, Martin? Yes, you have a
choice. Is there a choice here? Mhm. No,
they're not there.
No choice whatsoever.
13th rule.
To be right in everything, we had always
to hold that the white which I see is
black
if the hierarchical church so decides
it. Believing that between Christ our
Lord, the bridegroom, and the church his
bride, there is the same spirit which
governs and directs us for the salvation
of our souls.
Because by the same spirit and our Lord,
who gave the 10 Commandments, our holy
mother the church is directed and
governed.
But those commandments have been changed
in the catechism, right?
Yes.
So, which lord gave them?
Well, the enemy of God.
You're right, Martin, because the Lord
says, "I change not. I do not alter what
went out of my mouth."
But these people have a changed set of
commandments, so which lord then gave
them that false set of commandments?
That lord of the earth. Which allows
them
to venerate relics and images
and all of these things. Now, when you
internalize that in your imagination
Mhm. and you eventually get to the point
where you physically in your imagination
have contact with that world, you're
part of the occult world. Yes, because
Satan sits behind all of this.
Correct.
So, the Jesuits have to obey perinde
ac cadaver, like a corpse. Loyola wrote,
"Even if God gave you an animal without
senses or master, you will not hesitate
to obey him as master and guide
because God ordained it to be so." The
constitutions repeat 500 times that one
must see Christ in the person of the
general.
So, you have the white pope and you have
the black pope. That's yin-yang. That's
Eastern mysticism.
So, Martin, these exercises, now we
could go into greater details because
when he talks about visualization,
he says you must use all the senses.
Yes. All of them. All five senses.
So, when you visualize that you are,
let's say, in the presence of Christ or
in the presence of Mary his mother,
you must see her
with the spiritual imagination.
You must smell her.
You must touch her.
You must hear her.
So, that apparition that you imagine
becomes a reality
because you have incorporated her into
your senses, and then when she speaks to
you,
that becomes the word of God.
And you must listen to it.
But have you tested that spirit when it
tells you you can change the
commandments of God? No. No.
So, this kind of training is alive and
well Yes.
and has infiltrated the entire world.
Correct. Protestant churches have
put a Christian label on this.
Absolutely.
So, today we have Ignatian retreats all
over the world, and as we have seen, you
have to do this on an annual basis in
some form or another.
And the Jesuits have infiltrated
Protestantism and brought this Ignatian
spirituality into the churches without
them knowing it. Correct.
So, Ignatian trick retreats and
spiritual exercises, an eight-day
Ignatian retreat for priest, religious
deacons, lay ministers by Thomas Roach,
Society of Jesus, uses contemplation and
themes of spiritual exercises and other
meditations to guide the reader
prayerfully into the heart of an
Ignatian retreat.
And basically, how do you serve?
Serve what?
The interests of the church. Correct.
Here's another one, the Jesuit review.
You can download the spiritual exercises
from this website.
So, the first installment of Jesuit
review offers an introduction to the
spiritual exercises
and uh, you know, you can you can read
it there together with Father Joseph
Tetlow, Society of Jesus, and he writes,
"Philosophy
continues at the heart of the Jesuit
liberal arts curriculum because more
than any other discipline,
it can provoke the intellectual
conversion
of the conventional thinker to the
principled reflection."
Uh, what did Martin Luther say in those
quotes in the beginning?
What is the value of this according to
Martin Luther?
Nothing. Zero. Nothing. No value
whatsoever.
It might be of some value in the
temporal world.
Yes. It might be
important for the world and for the
the way people view you,
but it's got zero value. With God.
With God. Exactly the same as those
those important names
that meant nothing in the eyes of God.
Here's a quote from Richard M. Gula,
Jesuit, of course,
and professor.
"Our own Jordan experience must be the
keystone experience for measuring all
other experiences as being experiences
of God.
It requires such discipline as a
continuous rhythm of prayer, leisure,
silence, exercise to nurture physical
and emotional health, and other
spiritual exercises
such as spiritual direction,
dream work,
fasting,
and whatever else enables us to unlock
our imaginations
and to let go of those paralyzing
attachments which prevents us from being
aware of God's presence in our lives
and from bringing our lives into the
drift of our deepest desires.
The judgment of which the process of
discernment leads will be as true for us
as the freedom with which we make it."
Now, Martin,
there is not one ounce
not one nanogram of biblical
spirituality in that statement. No.
So, where do you get your discernment
from?
Where do you get your information from
as to what the will of God is? Well,
from your inner self.
And that is being fueled
by demonic spirits, to put it bluntly.
How do we know it's demonic? Because
they change the word of God.
So, Martin,
now that we've seen what the basis of
Ignatian spirituality is
and what fuels the morality of Pope
Francis, which in turn fuels the
morality of the world,
Yes. which in turn will be incorporated
in legislation,
do you,
as a Bible-believing
person, want to be part of that
spirituality? No.
Would you like Martin Luther say it is
time to speak?
Yes, definitely. And it is important
because this, like you mentioned
earlier, has infiltrated churches,
Protestant, everywhere. All of the
things, the retreats that the churches
have, they're based on Ignatian
spirituality.
When you look at the structures that
they have,
even in courses like the Alpha course
and all of those, they're all steeped
with Ignatian spirituality.
And when you start candle rituals and
contemplations and all of these and
bringing in Eastern mysticism,
Yes, because now you've got Christian
yoga. Yes, all of this links in to all
this false spirituality.
Yes, and people are being sucked into
it.
And there will have to come a very clear
divide between those
who find this information, this word of
God, precious Mhm. and those who don't.
You know, Martin,
before I end, let me just go
if you don't mind, just
never mind. off the cuff, just go there.
Go to the very first Psalm in the Bible.
There's a reason why that Psalm is the
first Psalm, by the way.
It's a very short Psalm,
but it set sets the stage. In fact, the
very the first two Psalms
set the stage for the entire book of
Psalms,
which was the hymnal
of the Hebrews. This is what they sang.
And you know, the hymnal of the of the
Hebrews and the words that they entail
are so full of meaning and depth. That's
where you get your spirituality, right?
Yes. And
I know that this is not part of the
discussion, but just as a counter to all
of this that we've seen,
Correct. let's just look at this.
where you get that spirituality
Yes.
Psalms 1. Blessed is the man that
walketh not in the counsel of the
ungodly,
nor standeth in the way of sinners,
nor sitteth in the seat of the scornful.
But his delight is in the law of the
Lord, and in his law does he meditate
day and night. This is where I get my
spirituality. Now, Martin,
look at that first verse.
Blessed is the man that walketh not in
the counsel,
nor standeth
in the way of the sinner, nor
sitteth. There's a progression.
There's a progression
from walking
to standing
to sitting.
So, when you walk with the wicked,
eventually you will stop and start
talking to them.
And eventually you will sit with them.
And uh eventually you might actually
become a chairman
sitting on a chair.
Now,
in uh Afrikaans, you are Afrikaans.
The word chairman
in Afrikaans is voorsitter.
Did you get that? Voorsitter.
Voor is in the front. And the sitter is
someone who sits.
So, the sitting in front, the one who
controls the issue.
So, Martin,
when you start walking in the counsel of
the ungodly,
in other words, those that do not take
their spirituality from this book, but
from another source,
eventually you will stand and talk to
them.
And eventually you will sit down with
them. Then you're sitting in the
ecumenical council.
What if you become a chairperson in one
of their councils?
Then you've got a problem. Yeah, we made
a problem, right? Then you have been
swallowed hook, line, and sinker. Beware
lest we walk that road.
But our delight should be in the law of
the Lord, and in his law does he
meditate day and night.
He shall be like a tree planted by the
rivers of water that bringeth forth his
fruit in his season. His leaf also shall
not wither, and whatsoever he doeth
shall prosper. This is the exact
opposite
of Ignatian spirituality.
The ungodly are not so,
but are like the chaff which the wind
driveth away. Therefore, the ungodly
shall not stand in the judgment,
nor sinners in the congregation of the
righteous.
For the Lord knoweth the way of the
righteous, but the way of the ungodly
shall perish.
So, this Psalm sets the tone.
Don't walk with them.
Don't stand with them. And don't. Don't
sit with them.
It's a progression.
And stick to the Bible, the Torah, the
law of God, the law and the prophets.
And then you'll be like a tree planted.
And the second Psalm
tells us
around whom our spirituality should
resolve, not some earthly impostor
who gets his
spirituality
from a non-biblical source.
Why do the heathen rage and the people
imagine vain things?
The kings of the earth set themselves,
and the rulers take counsel together
against the Lord and against his
anointed, saying,
"Let us break their bands asunder and
cast away their cords from us."
So, they feel there's something in God's
word that is holding them back.
And that's the law of God.
Let's break those cords. Let
"Do what thou wilt be the whole of the
law." Isn't that what they're saying?
Yes, so let us break their bands
asunder, cast away their cords from us,
and let us get our spirituality from
another source, by our imagination and
not by the word of God.
He that
sitteth in heaven
shall laugh.
The Lord shall have them in derision.
Then shall he speak unto them in his
wrath and vex them in his sore
displeasure.
Yet, and now listen to this, yet have I
set my king upon my holy hill of Zion.
I will declare the decree, the Lord has
said unto me, "Thou art my son. This day
have I begotten thee." Who's the real
king, Martin?
Jesus.
Not some earthly one that I set in his
place.
Right?
"Ask of me, and I shall give thee the
heathen for thine inheritance and the
uttermost parts of the earth for thy
possession." That's a Messianic promise.
"Thou shalt break them with a rod of
iron. Thou shalt dash them in pieces
like a potter's vessel."
Jesus will be the ultimate ruler. If you
put your faith in an earthly one, you
will be disappointed.
Including yourself.
Be wise now, therefore, oh ye kings, be
instructed, ye judges of the earth.
Serve the Lord with fear, and rejoice
with trembling.
Ah, and this verse, Martin, kiss the son
with a capital S.
Lest he be angry,
and ye perish from the way,
when his wrath is kindled but a little.
Blessed are they
that put his trust in him.
Martin,
as for me and my house, I want to follow
that.
Don't go and sit
and try to smell and touch and do all
these things.
Open this word, read through it,
and that's where your spirituality comes
from. Let's pray.
Heavenly Father,
what a contrast.
What a
plot
to dethrone the king of heaven.
Lord, let us kiss the son lest we perish
in Jesus' name. Amen.
Thank you for watching this video.
To subscribe, click here.
When the bell appears,
click again to get notifications.
To watch the next video,
click here.
Thank you.